aujourd'hui à paris fait 28
degrés ce début du printemps
tout le monde sort et pour
tourner un peu boudeuse parce
que ça fait sale soleil
mais je suis déjà en profiter
pour devenir américain andré
gorz
or jeudi les toulousains
bonjour c'est plutôt réussi
catherine oger
tout d'abord je me suis procuré
un avantage
dans la publicité justice
censée apaiser un peu le feu du
rasoir
alors j'ai essayé
voire de savoir pas du tout
elle est parfaitement clair
totalement imprévue du visage
après je me suis décidé à
faire bonne mesure
je serai un petit peu musclé
mauvaise soirée mais à chaque
fois de se défaire de l'année
le faire progressivement ça
le mardi est un petit peu
le problème c'est que souvent
un petit ticket
l'ambiance ne serait que ça
fasse mal
ils savent comment la tamise qui
travaillent à moi justement au
festival
à cet égard at-il dit à l'afp
on en
et là le lendemain
j'ai carrément mal pendant une
semaine
grégoire c'est absolument
douloureux
je suis pas plus que cela voilà
pourquoi moi je fais de la muscu
les écarts types de mes
passions des équipiers au maire
célébrant ténébreux et le
brun ténébreux john être
captées m
pourquoi il était du même
auteur
plante de normaliser les
ténébreux dans l'épisode
sonne peut-être comme ça et
maintenant il est comme ça
des latics à santiago
alors que les blancs
on ne sait rien entendu
tandja le tireur
les routes les brunes
les choses ténébreux
ça existe pas
a city racing
je suis plus désolé
toutefois je ne pourrai jamais
tous mes bras
enfin pourrait permettre
d'amender les je pense qu'il
faudrait que je fasse
ce qu'on doit faire pour maigrir
un peu comme les maquilleurs
pour dire bonjour de sa maman
super fort
c'est super chiant d'ailleurs
pour ce n'est pas légal
ses trois combats en ville
ou alors d'une canette de bière
avec un budget par exemple
moi j'aurais bien aimé
ce qui peut m'aider à le
restaurer
à cet instant
c'est vraiment la vedette
ou encore craqué
moi ça ne fait aucun bruit
quelques semaines seulement
deux fois avant de tout plaquer
et austerlitz commencé ma
carrière vétérinaire
mais bon le genre humain
je ne descends pas content
comme vous êtes de plus en plus
nombreux sur la page facebook
format dvd vidéo
c'est qu'à la fin on pouvait me
sens entre mm
jonquière
pour vous
ils vont samedi